so most people are dreamers would you
say i would say so most people got a
dream
but you know martin luther king had a
dream right we all get a dream everyone
wants to be something yeah but
history favors the doers
not the dreamer just do it just do it
that's right nike vibes so the hard
truth is dreaming alone won't make your
dreams possible you got to do some [ __ ]
yeah i mean you got to do it do over
dream is great
make it just doing is better
okay so you know who loves doing
warren buffett yeah
nike but warren buffett does love um
doing so warren buffett actually broke
down four ways that you can go from
being a dreamer to a doer and i actually
read this i was like you know what i
like this
warren that people need to know about
this that people need to know what you
got right there
let's see what a picture of warren
buffett looks like i like the article
but i like faces better there he is
there's warren because we're going to
talk about the four things here are the
four things that warren buffett explains
that can make you go from a dreamer to a
doer let me just give you the quick list
real quick and then we'll get into them
number one pick your friends
wisely respect number two go to bed a
little smarter
each and every day number three improve
your communication skills we'll break
down what that means and we'll
communicate and number four
just say
no oh what is that you know the power of
no
so let's get into these choices
number one pick your friends wisely
here's what warren buffett had to say
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so it's
important to associate your people that
are better
than yourself the friends you will have
the friends you have will form you as
you go through life cool amen i say this
all the time your network is your net
worth you you put together the five
people you hang out with the most i'll
show you your future it is what it is
okay
so warren buffett has basically spelled
that out for us that your network is
your net worth you know collectively the
people you hang out with that's your
future right there so what does that
mean you're going to go through life and
you're going to make friends i'm still
like
my sister goes it's a random story my
sister goes through friends like water
every week she's got a new friend she's
got a new friend
um i've had my same best friend since
elementary school i have my same friends
since middle school since high school
since college since after college i
collect friends that's you know some
people collect trading cards some people
are car people i like friends i got a
lot of friends okay
but the friends that i i'm friends with
i don't necessarily deal with in a
business capacity i'm constantly looking
for people that i can upgrade my
business side of things
to improve just because i'm friends with
you doesn't mean we need to constantly
be
networking and doing business together
like there's a reason that i joined pbd
i'm like who's the freaking best guy
that i can team up with pvd
okay we weren't best friends we're
friends we're tight but that's someone
you can level up with so this is
basically saying team up with people
that are better than yourself or team up
with people that have a different skill
set than you so and that the flip side
of that is you might be friends with
somebody for a long time but at some
point you might have to cut them off and
i don't mean for good like never talk to
you again but it's like
you know so and so we hang out we have a
good time we get drunk we get wasted but
it's it's kind of that's it there's
nothing there that's it we're not we're
not making moves we're not making money
it's just
the good times are great but the good
times don't last forever so basically
warren buffett's saying is choose your
friends wisely right not everybody is
meant to be in your life for your entire
life
okay you can be friends with somebody on
facebook but not everybody you hang out
with needs to be in your life the better
you can upgrade uh the better off you'll
be in the long run you have any friends
like this that you're like you know what
dude yeah no there are there are friends
i have i'm as you're saying this i'm
thinking of that i'm like yeah that's
what people should be thinking about
right now who are my friends here's my
challenge to everybody listening i see
people making comments
write down the people you hang out with
the most
and then
next to that is
write down to the people you want to
hang out with the most that will
actually be the most beneficial in your
life and see if those lists match up if
the five that are on your list that you
hang out with the most are in fact the
five people that'll help you improve
your life the most boom you're winning
but if the five people on the left side
of your list
have nothing to do with the people on
the right side of your list maybe you
need to take warren buffett's advice as
you were saying yeah no it's just
exactly that it's like wow and then just
naturally you start kind of going away
from those people because you're
starting to hang out with better people
and then those people are just stuck
doing nothing yeah you want to be stuck
doing nothing no and it and this isn't a
knock on those friends i have friends
that i loved it like i have a couple
people 100 percent i'm not going to say
i love this guy that's my guy that's my
if i see him it's hug love this guy
but he's not improving in life yeah and
it's not my job to make him improve in
life and if i see him we'll grab a beer
we'll hang out whatever
but i'm not trying to do business with
this person so at some point love you
bro i see you when i see you you're my
guy we went to elementary school
together
but i'm going this way you keep doing
what you got to do and it's tough to do
but again not everybody that's been in
your life your whole life needs to stay
in your life for the rest of your life
so it is what it is use your time wisely
number two
go to bed a little smarter each and
every day all right so warren buffett
reads a lot i think the stats are show
like he says 80 percent of his day he
spends reading
for them for the rest of us that's super
aggressive 80 of the day yeah exactly
when you're worth you know 100 billion
dollars what else are you gonna what you
know what uh you're 90 years old so it's
aggressive i get it but the question is
how much are you reading
how much are you improving how much are
you getting better how much are you
spending time strategizing improving
getting better working out your mind
working out your body all good you know
pat pbd
you know he says there's four things to
um cornerstones of improvement he says
outwork
out improve
out strategize outlast so life's a
marathon not a sprint so if you're
getting better it's the compound
interest effect every night if you're
getting better i learned something today
i got smarter today i didn't know about
that you know what i [ __ ] up with this
today let me improve upon that but if
you do that every single day and you
make a conscious effort that every day
you're going to improve
talk to me in 365 days talk to me two
years down the road talk to me three
years down the road you know there's
some people that you know thanks for the
advice one more buffett gives advice
you might want to listen number three
improve your communication skills he
says this one way to become
worth
50 more is to hone your communication
skills both written and verbal david i
give you a book recommendation yesterday
what was the book recommendation how to
make friends and what was the yeah how
to win friends influence people
influence people i'm telling you right
now like sometimes i'll sit with pat i'm
not a avid reader i've read some books
i've read a lot of financial books
self-help books i don't read a lot of
like
harry potter stuff so pat always given
book recommendations so pat's like five
times a podcast read this book read this
book read this book sometimes i will
sometimes i mean i've got a million
things going on i can't always read the
book of the day
but one book that everybody that's
listening to this podcast if you
actually want to improve your network
your net worth right you want to
understand how people work if you're in
sales read this book how to win friends
and influence people i'm telling you i
think it was dale carnegie who wrote
this book um for someone like you that's
already a people person yeah it'll just
sharpen you all right for somebody
that's not a people person this will
teach you how to become a people person
for me i was always a people person so
when i read the book they're basically
saying if you actually care about people
and have interest in people
this book will serve you well i'm like
hey i like people
person yeah people like me i'm a likable
person i think right uh super good some
of the things that some tips this book
as far as communication remembering
people's names
remembering people's names they say that
a person's name is literally the most
important thing in their life like your
name is david has everybody like hey
danny what's up you're like i will
[ __ ] murder your face yeah yeah yeah
it's the worst yeah if someone's like
hey what's your name is it alex
yeah yeah it's it's so funny to say that
uh i hate you back in college i was in a
uh i was working at this with this
tattoo lady she did some of my tattoos
and dude i swear to you we went to
gainesville and i i can put money on it
my life on it she did not know my name
that's the worst we went there in the
same car for hours yes and she would
always find ways to avoid my name she's
super nice
buddy yeah
i'm here with my uh
apprentice yeah what's no what's my name
nicole say it what's my name
um snl skit
john you've worked with this person for
12 years they sent a cubicle across from
you
what's her name
stacy
stacy
robin oh right
yeah remembering people's names huge
anyway that's part of this book how to
win friends influence people a couple
other things
compliment do your best to compliment
people not criticize
right if you [ __ ] up
apologize and not just apologize
apologize deeply my bad i i feel so
stupid that i did this i i will never
mess up again i feel horrible that's my
bad like what is someone going to say to
that yeah it is your bet it totally is
all right
improve i will
improve outlast i'll strategize all that
fun stuff and then the the
the the other stuff with that
and ask questions or ask questions and
listen you know they say that all the
time you got one mouth and two ears for
a reason that's part of the how to win
friends and influencing people people
love
talking about themselves david how you
doing doing well tell me about yourself
just chilling yeah you love talking
about yourself there it was yep there it
is yeah
anyway
that's part of um
warren buffett's
advice that's number three and number
four
say no
sometimes you just gotta say
no like remember like the say no to
drugs
okay there's other things you can say no
to because why the greatest commodity
you have is your time
time is money drugs too apparently uh so
the difference between this is what
warren buffett says the difference
between successful people and the really
successful people is that the really
successful people
know how to say
no to almost everything that is not
worth their time yeah that is not worth
their time so be very mindful of what
you say yes and no to remember the movie
yes man i love that movie it was a great
movie yeah i tried it yeah it didn't
work out you you say yes to everything
you're gonna have a lot of uh tough
experiences in your life right yeah not
everything's gonna go great yeah i ended
up as production coordinator this media
company
yes yes yeah anyway
you can't be too available there's some
things
hey i got a big i got a big thing uh due
on monday it's saturday night yo let's
go out
yeah whatever the decision is that
that'll you know ah [ __ ] it let's go
yeah no no i don't i can't i i really
have to get this done yeah right
yeah the fomo is not like fomo's real
almost real but like once you get your
thing done i mean it's so much it's you
you're like thank god i didn't go out i
would have never done yeah so don't be
afraid to say no anyway that's warren
buffett he's only the greatest investor
of all time so what does he know right
exactly okay
um
that's great advice from warren buffett
again just to recap that warren
buffett's four ways you can go from
being a dreamer to a doer number one
pick your friends wisely number two go
to bed a little smarter each and every
night number three improve your
communication skills we talked about how
to win friends and influence people and
number four
just say
no
to drugs
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro